ouais ça moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui certainement vu la situation
économique dans laquelle nous sommes
je pense que effectivement le cinéma de
robert guédiguian et d'actualité
ça me dérangerait profondément parce que
je suis d'une génération qui adore aller
dans une salle de cinéma pour pour
m'asseoir à côté de gens que je ne
connais pas et voilà à les plateformes
jeudi mal j'avoue sincèrement ça veut
pas dire que je que je ne m'en sers pas
que je regarde pas certains films en
plateformes pc
c'est une perte d'humanité je crois
qu'il faut plus d'un an pour tirer les
leçons de 2020 est d'autant plus que
cette année a été une année assez
étrange pour le cinéma
ça prend ça prend un peu de temps oui
mais peut-être que on va on va y arriver
on va y arriver à un moment mois d'août
mais on va y arriver de toute façon
c'est inéluctable
il ya des phénomènes de solidarité qui
se sont mis en place qui ont été
absolument extraordinaire tout le monde
est quand même plus ou moins un peu
retomber dans les habitudes de avant la
pandémie
mais là comme ça fait quand même un
moment que on est tous prêts sur et
peut-être que on va commencer vraiment à
réfléchir et à réfléchir ensemble ça
serait pas mal
[Musique]
qui a encore des gens qui meurent qui
tombe au fond de l'eau et la
méditerranée de cimetière de plus
en plus grand et si vous voulez et face
à une année
d'anxiété tout le monde vit dans la peur
où tout le monde est dans une situation
à port hope you gêne et ben il ya cette
espèce de deux phénomènes très comment
dire très individualiste très égoïste et
la seule chose que j'ai envie de dire
c'est que ce qu'on ne se courent pas en
ce moment
et bien c'est peut-être quelque chose
qui nous restera sur l'estomac parce que
comme on ne sait pas où on va peut-être
que nous aussi un jour on aura besoin de
secours et je sais pas si nous serons là
voilà ce serait bien ce serait bien
pensé à tout ça
[Musique]